the Biden administer the abiding agenda
is as we know failing on every front
obviously and rather than admit their
shortcomings their response is always
the same double and triple down on more
destructive delusional and dangerous
far-left lunacy for example we are now
learning more about a new 1.5 billion
that's with a B dollar Grant from the
Transportation Department to fund woke
pet projects surrounding so-called
racial equity and economy killing
climate change initiatives and the best
part all of the funds are coming from
the infrastructure bill that Biden
signed last year but just like their
covert relief bill wasn't actually about
covid the infrastructure Bill covers way
more than traditional infrastructure
here with more giving us a bit more
background and Analysis former HUD
secretary is one of our favorites of
course Dr Ben Carson Dr Carson thank you
for joining me tonight we know that the
nations in some degree of trouble you
are an example of the the kind of man
that this nation produces and delivers
to help the American people you serve
you serve this country you serve her now
with the work that you do what 1.5
billion dollars the the difference that
kind of money could make in the quality
of people's lives is the economy
continues to crumble uh would be
astounding what do you say when it comes
to this kind of spending of money on
absurd projects
well it's rather quite sad that we would
uh use this excuse to funnel money in
for the pet projects the Christmas wish
list of the uh woke left
and
singling out you know ratio favorites
that doesn't really do anything if you
think back to the last Administration
it was a philosophy that a rising tide
floats all boats and we had the lowest
unemployment for minorities particularly
blacks and Hispanics
we had the highest wages we had prison
reform
we created a situation where the hbcus
didn't have to come with Cup in hand
every year
I mean there was a whole plethora of
things that really worked much better
than this Equity stuff
and if people would just stop and
evaluate things on their face as opposed
to listening to the propaganda I think
we'd be much better off but these gifts
are used to further divide the American
population if you favor one group or or
another all you're going to do is create
tension and we've gotten to the point
where we think that we're enemies we the
American people we're not each other's
enemies the enemies are those purveyors
of hatred and division who seem to have
a tremendous mouthpiece and and
facilitated by the media
you know it's I think you're absolutely
right and it's very wise assessment
there because when we're looking at the
nature of what they would propose things
like from the Department of
Transportation we've heard them talk
about the racism of highways and how
every decision effectively that's made
is this structural racism and that money
somehow is going to cure that and what
it makes everybody think is that the
system you can't win at all you're lost
that even the roads are against you
isn't it doesn't that go too far or do
you think the Democrats actually believe
that
I don't think they believe it but they
have discovered ways to manipulate
people and and that's really the key if
they were really interested they'd be
dealing with what you were just talking
about you know the Border we've got all
kind of people coming into this country
including people who want to destroy
this country and uh it's only the grace
of God that's saving us we certainly
don't have a government that seems to
understand the dangers that are
presented by doing things like they're
doing
and you know that's that's really the
reason that the American Cornerstone was
created to help Focus people on the
things that made this into a great
nation things that are being attacked on
a daily basis our faith and our families
and we're going to have to be smart
enough to recognize what's going on and
not allow ourselves to be manipulated
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else